the when the business opens back up are
they going to be rehired
and so the concern is you know i met a
woman who's in her 60s
who has been working for a long time in
the industry and concerned that
that when it opens back up they're going
to hire younger people
and then she'll be without obviously an
income and all the benefits that come
with a job
so these are some of the residual
impacts of this moment
and it's heartbreaking but at the same
time you know look at these
incredible people who are donating their
time
um and we've seen this around the
country people who are donating their
time at
food banks who themselves are out of a
job and
i do believe this is a moment that
really is highlighting
the beauty of human character in times
of crisis
and the american rescue plan is meant to
also meet the moment in terms of doing
what our government should be doing
which is
bringing relief bringing help to folks
when they need it most
madam vice president
one that people are suffering but we
knew that before
and we knew it based on the statistics
but but the stories
add much more color to that point right
when you hear that folks
you know folks want to work and for
those who are in industries where they
may not get rehired
what that is going to mean for them in
terms of a prolonged
suffering and and that was really the
point of the stories that i heard today
um what have i learned i've learned the
the character
of people to help one another and
and what that has meant to actually keep
things going through this
year long um and it's not over crisis
well first of all what i want to do is
make sure that people know what they're
entitled to in the american rescue plan
and so that is about the 1400
checks the child tax credit uh part of
what the president and i are talking
about is also reminding people to
file their taxes we've got 30 days to do
it before april 15th
um there are a number of folks who don't
file taxes if their income is too low
but it would actually help them get
their benefits quicker and maybe even
direct deposits if they file their taxes
now so we want to encourage people to do
that
so that they know what their rights are
right now
we don't we want to avoid a situation
where folks are unaware of what they're
entitled to and then this moment passes
and they don't get the full relief
that they're entitled to get so one more
question are you i mean could you say
whether
tax increases are under consideration as
part of the next phase of this recovery
act
we haven't really figured out what the
next phase is going to be to be honest
with you
and we're going to make those decisions
you know this just happened last week
and we want to get on the road to make
sure people know what it is
so i'll keep you posted thank you madam
vice president
the white house has said the white house
has said repeatedly that
that this is a very popular law if
that's the case
why is it important to get out and sell
it it's not selling it
it's literally letting people know their
rights right it's it's kind of like
you um you buy a product you've already
been sold on the product but you need
some directions on the box usually
right and so this is about hey know that
you're entitled to this file your
taxes so that you can speed up the
benefits that you're going to receive
um talk to your friends and neighbors
about getting vaccinations because we
are speeding up
the delivery and supply supply of
vaccinations and sites like unlv
this is these are the things we are
doing to let people know what they're
entitled to and to spread the word
think of it more as a public education
campaign this is what's happening this
is what you're entitled to receive
and so go out there and get it thank you